coppy do my makeup first I look good
like oh there's gonna be uses what's up
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls and
welcome to the first episode of the
trash taste podcast how are ya
the official first episode the official
first episode we finally made it
I'm your host for today Joey and joining
me every week is Scott and Connor hey
guys so yeah it's finally happened it's
finally happening oh my god you do not
know how long we've been planning this
and how long we wanted this to have this
[ __ ] like how long has it been I mean I
mean we've been conceptualizing this
podcast like what over yeah it's been
yeah a year at least profs possibly
years cuz I mean when we decided we were
gonna move to Japan I think the first
thing in our mind was what we gonna make
a podcast yeah yeah but but I think it
were even before that the idea of just
us finally getting into a room and just
you know not doing a one-off collab but
doing like a continual collab has been
you know in our minds for ages yeah I
want to say several years yes at least
almost as known as late as long as I've
known you was like you don't really cool
a podcast I'm just left out here iris
tacked on at the end no let's talk about
that like how we first met each other
because I think that's a good
introduction to this podcast and how
we've because you never know there might
be someone watching who doesn't know
like who's that guy exactly right hi I'm
Connor our Channel
I'm pretty surprised if there is someone
watching this post episode who doesn't
know like all three of us yeah exactly
maybe oh maybe they've seen us if you
did then can you please tell us in the
comments below how you found this video
yeah cuz we're just so famous that you
have know it yes but not knowing who we
are I swear I'm so yeah let's actually
you know what before we talk about that
we should talk about what this podcast
is because it's so was so light excited
I'm finally excited to get this thing
off the ground so basically trash taste
as the name implies is a podcast where
we us three and maybe
even a guest you never know comes onto
the show and we basically talk about our
trash taste whether it comes to anime
manga just otaku culture in general or
you never know we might talk about
whatever the [ __ ] we want
who knows yeah cuz if you didn't know we
are all like anime youtubers yeah so
know this guy called the anime man this
guy called c-dog bar which God bow yeah
that too fast and Virginia is all the
comments from Virginia it's okay cuz the
amount of years that I still get
comments which is like they call me geek
UK and not get up I mean listen people
might call you Kiki okay but I still
know you as the an amazing okay in but
in the thumbnails in the old thumbnails
that's how I knew I was watching an
anime zone I'm actually curious how long
have you been watching my videos because
this ties into how we first met as well
I've known you I mean I obviously as I
said I've known you since at the animes
on it that's like that's the line so
it's like a long time but I think I like
I watched you probably not knowing that
you will like this like YouTube
personality because yeah yeah Sam yeah I
like cuz I was in like a weird state I
don't think I discovered youtubers until
maybe about 2011 yeah because they've
been around for a long time since then
yeah and obviously you've been around
since then but I never like went onto
YouTube being like I'm gonna go check
out my favorite YouTube I couldn't just
use YouTube up until around 2011 I think
I just use youtubers to like either
watch music all this in the music videos
or just to like oh this is an
interesting looking video yeah and I
think a couple of your videos will like
the interesting looking ones I think I
remember actually the first video I ever
watched from you surprisingly was not a
verb ridged oh sure I watched saver
bridge when I like the idea of an like a
breeding that sounds fun but tedious is
fun but um no I think the first video
what from you was
I probably want to say it's the size
review oh my god like the one you didn't
like mm I never even saw your IVA
aver a bridge yeah I just excited watch
Davis I was like why would i watch the
upper I don't even know what this is why
would I watch that so I think I watched
some of your stuff I just knew you
always the British one yeah my brand
yeah that was like it was like Tristan
and then you in my mind I think that was
it to a lot of people when yes when I
got into it like 2013 I stopped watching
YouTube alone especially anime stuff
right yeah but they're so how long have
you been doing YouTube for I've been
doing it since 2007 oh he's like an
actual OG I'm like I'll have to like
trace back but I'm think I'm like the
fifth ever anime youtuber Wow of all the
time might be like fourth or fifth but
I've been there since the beginning I
can recite the entire history of a knee
tube which we're definitely gonna do
with this episode because there there's
a lot to say but now like I remember the
first I can't remember what the exact
first video I saw from you Joey but I
remember your video is just getting
recommended to be constantly and I'm
just like my first thought was how has
no one taken to handle the anime I've
been on YouTube for so many [ __ ]
years and just now someone is called the
animate there's no [ __ ] no but the thing
is some what did take the handle
animator oh because that's why like like
even my like my YouTube URL and like my
Twitter and everything it's the anime
man but so and I it's a 1 because
somebody like Facebook Twitter Instagram
like YouTube someone took the anime man
it was like this guy who never uploaded
any videos haha and he's been arrested
like 2007 yeah it's always just like oh
man you are such a son of a [ __ ] so I
was like well what am I gonna do alright
[ __ ] one somehow that caught on I
don't know yeah [ __ ] but yeah I mean I
regret that name I mean it works for SEO
verow because the reason I was called
the anime zone is because back in the
day when you could just type in anime
and it was just all my videos I'm like
man I've won this game
I'm playing the game correctly and then
I came along a hold my beer exactly
you're in this arm I'm the man but I
remember the first time I was I mean I
don't think I ever saw one of your
videos the first time I heard about you
Connor was actually when you auditioned
for one of my bridge series so really
yeah yes I haven't told you story to Joe
yeah I did a casting call for one of the
in minutes videos right and I told
people to send in their demo trying to
remember what this was yeah and so I
asked people to send in their demo reel
and most people send in their demo reel
and this and this guy this [ __ ]
doesn't even send in a demo reel he just
sends in a YouTube video of him doing
League of left leg of legend character
why you should also never do that
yourself yeah don't do that we're gonna
someone asked for demos send a demo reel
yeah no I think at the time I didn't
have a character demo reel chief I still
don't have a character demo reel because
I never needed it okay his things well a
lot of character demos on Twitter you'll
hear them they're really really bad yeah
and the thing is when you're making it
yourself you don't have anyone to say
like hey this voice kind of sucks so
like every time I've made a professional
demo I've had like a director who's like
hand shows and every scene and told me
what to do yeah and then it sounds good
because someone who can hear your voice
and be like I'll do this and that but
back then I didn't know that and this
was before I started doing a lot of
professional staff in that yeah it's
great way to introduce yourself or
someone this is okay this is also
another thing you shouldn't send a demo
to someone if it's garbage cuz you're
gonna like this guy still remembers that
[ __ ] I remember because he was the only
person who didn't send a demo reel or
just sent a YouTube video of him doing
impressions
Melisande like if there is a like a
checklist of things not to say our demo
do not send character impression that's
such a big that's such a big do you
remember which characters he did I think
so I think they were like I was just a
bunch of the manly guys from League of
Legends just anyone with a low voice
yeah oh no it's like it's been awesome
seeing you how far you've come from yeah
in a character impression real to you
like that was like I that must have been
just like a year or two after I started
as well and I still like you think that
you figure stuff out after a year but
like you realized when you look back
like you've still you didn't know [ __ ]
because what year did you start YouTube
ah YouTube I started 2015 2015 2015 2015
I started voice acting really in like
2013 late 2014 so that gave me a big
like advantage I went into it with like
a great microphone which I'm not voice
acting yeah yeah yeah and we'd find that
how I met you actually have the email
sent before we started recording this
we're gonna talk about like how we all
made want to help this guy was like I
don't think Joey remembers the first
time we met I think I do though okay
sorry to read the email that I saw this
is why I had what you send it to me
right yeah yeah so this is about like I
must have been like four months into me
doing YouTube I think I had like maybe
30 40 K sobs yeah I think Joey I think
he had like nine hundred K at this time
probably it was something like you had a
long yeah I think way more than I had
and so I sent you an email saying that's
Owen hello there my name is Connor
Connor or c-dawg VA on YouTube this
doesn't make any sense grammatically
or sit over there oh my eyes use commas
hello there my name is Connor or C dog
they own YouTube channel here okay
here's where it starts to get real crazy
yeah I've been working on a Levi versus
Sebastian rap
okay wait I'll finish it there likes it
and it is about 90% complete I noticed
you recently did a rap battle and it was
well done I couldn't have kissed your
ass more here huh it's more of an
insulting each other character rap I
have the voice of sebastian michaelis
english dubbed down to a tee wow really
wow wow well and i was wondering if
you'd like to be levi if you wish to
talk to me more about about it and the
logistics feel free to contact me on
skype I wanted this sound professional
spot yeah oldest reply to this email any
responses appreciate it but kind regards
sido views any of use my real name
seed okay and then Jerry replied saying
hi there sure sounds like fun smiley
face I had a do on skype we can talk
about it and I remember the first thing
that Jerry sent me was like yo your
voice is cool as [ __ ] yeah I still think
that so that's how I and she'd say I
thought that was so cool that you
actually replied cuz I'm not gonna lie
I'm kind of mean when I see a video
normally when it's like collab it's
normally like normally it's like I I
don't know what I want to do yet but I
want to collab you don't know what you
want to do so that's why I'm a year yeah
I [ __ ] remember that too because yeah
the the rap battle I did was oh so bad
don't watch it looks like I gotta prove
to you that I'm the best you want a
fight little email will be my guest the
full through the end until I got enough
on my chest but pretty bad it was pretty
[ __ ] bad at the time it was the first
time I ever used the green screen in my
like because I was in like my tiny
bedroom in Australia yeah there was no
place to like prop up the green screen
yeah what I had to do it so get her what
I have to do was I had to get the green
screen and literally like tape it to the
ceiling no I've done exactly the same
thing and like I had no light so you can
see my shadow [ __ ] flickering in and
out the whole video I only could entrap
at the time I'm a little bit better now
but yeah it was a what was it it was a
light no it was L from Death Note versus
Lelouch
from code right I remember I played
louche and another friend of mine played
L know and I think the video has like
half a million views
I don't know how yeah I mean this is
back when it was like epic Rap Battles
of History yeah that's like 2015 YouTube
yeah but basically like that kind of
somehow pulped off on my channel and
then yeah and then because I actually
was riding that with grey fox at the
time yeah amazing guy yeah and I thought
like we had it we had like a banger
we had like so many like grey fox had
made the tracks for many beads and they
were playing amazing and sending emails
that's such a Boomer way to slide into
something I mean now it's Twitter not to
mention we added each other on skype and
then I think like your Skype account got
hacked or something that uh I know I met
you but it was weird cuz I think Sydney
we I saw Sydney was following me
yeah it's not my fiancee yeah Anna I
think it followed her backs I knew of
Sydney and then Sydney a DM me she'll
say that she didn't Sydney DM me first
and she was like you going to MCM which
is a convention in London yeah okay and
then Sydney was like oh come come to
this meet up you can meet me and gone I
didn't get to meet gone who's too busy
so I turned up like an idiot was like hi
I'm like c-dawg
and stuff and everyone at the time I had
like 200k subscribers here's a
substantial amount yeah that time period
but it was funny because you had
audience that was vastly different from
their every other enemy still like that
it's it's gone like a lot lesser at the
time in around 2000 the peak of it at
2014 I had a 93 percent female audience
which is his nickname when we first met
him was the 93 % yeah
just like how's the 90% doing okay I got
bullied for it I really want to stop
it's 55 60 percent now it's level down
along yeah it was crazy there and that's
like all the youtubers in anime all
dudes there was like one or two girls
yeah all dudes so every time I turned up
to like an ana tuber Meetup everyone's
like who the [ __ ] is this guy
how does he got 200k yeah so I mean
that's how I met gone and then we went
from yeah can I tell the story about how
the first time we heard yeah cuz I don't
know where you're gonna start okay so
the first time we met in person
so it was like ax 2000 and is it 17 it
was 16 or 17 I think I think so
I knew Joey I didn't know that he knew
who I was right and vice versa a new god
but I didn't know if he knew me yeah so
this was back when I had like if you
didn't know I took a hiatus on on
YouTube for like two years because I got
a real time a real job and everything
like that and in that time I had gone
from being like one of the most popular
anime youtubers to just you know to
someone who taken i8s and in that time
Joey had like exploded like you you were
you reached numbers that's back in my
time I didn't know what's even [ __ ]
possible like you you were like close to
a million you were like like hot [ __ ] at
the time yeah so the first time welcome
so the first time I saw Joey we were
like in Little Tokyo or something
yeah yeah I remember exactly where it
was - it was that pot in like the back
half of Little Tokyo yeah right it's
like underneath a building and you go
into where the like a figurine shop yeah
and yeah and you were walking with Jeff
right yeah yeah that's why I Jeff
because I think Jeff said hello to misty
because they're both tall [ __ ]
he was just like standing next to two
[ __ ] skyscrapers well we're just
hanging out and I remember looking at
you and you look to me and we didn't say
[ __ ] to each other and I thought this I
thought this [ __ ] must hate me
this [ __ ] hates me and that's
the same time I like a gun I like looked
at each other in the eyes and in my head
I was like this guy definitely hates me
this guy hates my guts so I'm just like
man Joey's such an arrogant piece of
[ __ ] I can't believe this guy man but we
shook hands we were like hi I'm Joey
nice to meet you like hi I'm gone I said
that was it and that was it that was so
I've never heard this well because the
only people who were there was misty
Jeff iñaki yeah I'm thinking us too so
it was like very small yeah and then
what like fast forward like what two
years I think it was just I think it was
next year we might you might have been
even less than that when I came to Egypt
went on to a trip to Japan or something
and then you randomly deemed me yeah
yeah yeah like for some reason he
follows me so maybe she doesn't hate me
oh cool he's cool so yeah we sweet TMZ
chowder and then we met in Japan and
then we just like instantly Italy just
like [ __ ] great friends you know we
went to whinnies like no we met up in
Akihabara yeah and we like hung out a
little bit and then we went to an
izakaya and Elena yeah yeah it's all
like ridiculously missed the last room
yeah and then we were like oh it sounds
like a bromance we missed the last train
we had so much fun because we had the
moment when we just we were seeing it on
in there he's like izakaya and I was
like I thought you hated me and I was
like I thought you ate at me yeah and
then after that we had like a karaoke
nights where we yeah I think was like a
few days later yeah and I think that's
when the seeds of the podcast was sown I
think because we were up to we missed
last train and we were just with karaoke
with each other and Sydney and there was
like two other people
and then everyone else had fallen asleep
but it was just us to one other guy it
was like it was like 5:00 a.m. he didn't
know who we were like he didn't know
that we were like anime youtubes or
anything huh so we're up at 5:00 a.m.
drunk as [ __ ] and then me and Joey just
start hosting this panel for this one
guy karaoke microphone age like welcome
to yeah he didn't know who we were but
we still just host this anime panel for
him I don't name I didn't even know if
he watched anime or not but I'm like my
dear Joey what's your opinion on Bucky
Monica true who is best girl like an
hour then after that we were like we
need to host a panel together yeah and
we managed to do that last year ax which
was first time that was amazing yes yeah
like two three years in the making and
in between that we were like surely we
gotta make a podcast and here we are
after [ __ ] what three or four years
yeah from like first conception yeah and
like even like planning this whole
podcast out as well like toke up very
very long time because this is actually
a studio for it yes so we have to like
get our own studio as you can see as you
can see we're still working on it just
working on it but give us some time
stick just like getting a studio in in
Japan oh my god you're Toki oh my
[ __ ] god don't even get me started on
how hard that was okay I'm sure we can
talk about in future or experiences with
just renting yeah stuff in Japan my god
bear yeah no I you know what's funny
when you guys are like you said like
just click like that after you guys
start talking it's so like I think that
happens easily when you're both like
around the same like sub thing because
there's no question if you're trying to
leech off each other right yeah yeah
because I remember like when I when I
first started and when I was trying to
it like when we were like first like
hanging out I always feel like man they
wonder if I'm she's like a leech
I'd like a hundred and fifty two hundred
and they had like million-plus right so
you just get this thing in your head you
like my anime leeching do they think
that but then like when you get like I
think now I don't give a [ __ ] because
like I I'm here I mean like concerning
you and I yeah we popped off very
naturally because spoiler we never ended
up doing that no battle yeah yeah it
that just like disappeared because I
think the first time I like publicly did
something with you yeah was on your
stream yeah yeah you do broforce
together for like three yeah there's
still a pond on new to bar really yeah
they all yeah yeah yeah and then I think
we just I played a lot of games on your
stream with you and then I think we just
hung out at ax and you just went and
then obviously play like Metal Slug [ __ ]
oh my oh yah metal slugs on like my
favorite game and then I think we just
did British things and I feel like it's
so easy to befriend other British people
cuz it's just like we just get it I
don't know no like going off to what you
said about feeling like you're leaching
from something yeah it's it's weird
right because you can as someone who's
been in the position of you know not you
know being a smaller youtuber and a
larger youtuber it's you can kind of get
a sense just from meeting a person
especially if you meet them in real life
right online
it's so [ __ ] difficult as true to
gauge what a character what someone's
character is actually like and you know
if they're trying to you know leech off
you know get clout or whatever but
especially at a event like ax where the
real person comes out yeah yeah yeah you
can definitely get a better judge of
character at a convention or meeting
someone in real life yeah a big event
like ax
I think there's I'm also a lot with that
is that when you're at ax I think some
people think okay I've only got five
minutes with this guy you've got to like
befriend him yeah so they I think they
like sometimes they go overboard with
like trying to impress you where it's
like I mean one thing I've noticed with
when it comes to like cuz I've been to
so many conventions where like people
have come up to me just for that like
five minutes that they have time with
somebody yeah so I just I don't want to
say kiss us but you know when someone's
trying to kiss ass here yeah all like
but like the thing is is that like at
least earlier on when I would meet
people like that and they're trying to
be nice to me during those
five minutes I didn't know if they were
just trying to kiss my ass or if there
were genuinely nice people yeah but the
one way I found it is if they can I
guess like main try and maintain that
friendship with you and try and stay
contact with you after that event then I
think they're like genuinely nice people
yeah yeah because I I don't want to make
it sound like we all [ __ ] arseholes
you think I'm talking with hearing about
how you just message cornerback from
just that one email yeah I also remember
the point when I would just try to like
talk to everyone in class yeah but then
you get to a point when you see that
ninety percent of these emails in ninety
percent of these people talking to you
don't actually mean what they mean or
looking for something and you get a
sense force you get a sense for that as
time goes by so it's it's I feel like
you just glanced at an email now and you
know actually here's a question for you
what's the way I know you've got some
stories of this Connor Oh God
what does someone like the weirdest fan
emails you've ever received I get them
every week right I'd like to say every
week but it's like I've gotten somewhere
it's just like I think like I'm actually
scared to open it even though there's
like no attachments no links or anything
but even a subject title it's literally
just I open it and it says you're cool
open an email like that and like
midnight is like the scariest [ __ ] ever
because I'm just like did my computer
just get hacked I don't know if this is
like an elaborate like trojan or or if
it's just like a ten-year-old who's
learning to use an email for the first
time like I'm like thanks but when they
just send a link that's cool it's like
yeah yeah man I don't know I've got so
many stories I guess of emails because I
guess it's my fault because I kind of
encouraged it a little bit yeah yeah
I've made multiple videos where I've got
content from my email sometimes it's
good but then
so I think now since I've joined an
agency I feel bad for the agency where
they sometimes I get said luckily I
normally like delete the ones that I
know I like like just trolling the for
by agency you can see it because I don't
want some Japanese worker opening my
email and it being like hey I think your
dummy thick and I'm 13
[Laughter]
that's like you get stuff where they'll
say like they they want to date you and
I'll put their 13 and like that it's
just like is this Christmas in is Chris
Hansen emailing yeah I think I've spoke
about this in a video once but there was
a someone who emailed me and I still
remember this cuz like I hadn't
interacted to it and it was this
interaction where they sent me a script
of phone sex that we were gonna have so
it was like it was like what I actually
still have the script I'm not gonna read
it out cuz there's more to the story
that there's the reason why I decided to
not make it into a video yeah but it was
like a script and it was it was first it
was one script was me and her and there
was also a music setlist that she'd
chosen so there was when the music was
it was like pour some like sugar on me
oh my you know like the cheesiest song
and so I thought in my head cause back
then I read all of them in depth and I
thought wow this is a video idea if I
can like is going right and there's also
another script where as me having gay
sex with the sebastian michaelis of
course of course I mean that would be
expected funny that's like not the
weirdest story I'm surprised you didn't
make a video Wow okay so here's why and
I feel bad I hope this person isn't
watching so I interacted with them a bit
and they were like obviously I knew they
were gonna be strange right because ever
sends an email like that yeah and I
start interacting with them more and
more and then they started sending me
way too much information about
themselves
there's also another guy who sent me is
birth certificate by the way that's a
whole nother what oh don't do that
turn that stage don't do that I didn't
ask for his opening email was his my
birth ticket driving license address and
I was like what is
I also mentioned this I don't know which
video I said I just mentioned all this
but yeah so I replied to this person I
kept replying with them because they
kept replying with really funny stuff
right yeah I was like oh my god I can
get an amazing video out of this yeah
and then with the one thing they said
which made me think okay now I just have
to like completely scrap all this is
that they said like oh here are my
hobbies hobbies blah blah blah by the
way I'm in the Special Olympics team for
the USA but I was like like why you
shouldn't be sending me this and then I
explained to them you know I was like
hey maybe you shouldn't send this email
to me and you know I don't think this is
like yeah appropriate way and I'm really
sorry for like messing with your time
and stop it I just it was a whole thing
where I was like oh my god I'm an
[ __ ] and Jesus Christ like yeah but
yeah there's so many emails I've gotten
where I mean I made a whole video where
I went on a date with someone else yes a
date yeah from an email you were like
Kaunas gonna get canceled I remember you
pitching that video idea to me and I'm
just like I don't know that's the best
idea but I mean it turned out good video
yeah I pitched it to like 10 10 of our
friends and everyone's like no don't do
that don't do that I love hockey my
girlfriend was like genuinely worried
for you is like I really don't think I
watch the video they felt more concern
for the girl because we turned up with
light me Evon mood and another guy like
one go alone right so thank you no but
it was like I I'm a wholesome in the end
as well
she's very nice about it yeah yeah she's
like the video sounds good she just
walked into our casting couch
alright I don't get off that actually I
actually don't get that many weird
emails or weird fan mails yeah I don't
know I guess it's cuz I mostly talk
about anime and it's less about my own
personality I guess I don't know I guess
like one weird email ago recently which
wasn't even an email to me right so
someone used my email and pretended to
be me and emailed
studio wits
okay okay I got the email here actually
the emailed studio whit's pretending to
be me as they use my email and I got a
notification from the official studio
with like you know you know like the
automatic notification that says hey
you've submitted this email to us okay
so the email reads hello I am anime
reviewer giggle I will make a request of
you
many people want Eren and Mikasa to have
a relationship Eren X Mikasa I think if
this happens many people will enjoy the
anime more has to be a troll I would be
pleased with the development of events
in this direction I hope you will
evaluate my proposal I wish you good day
man this hazard email I said you contact
me for more to figure out the logistics
of Eren Mikasa oh no this is completely
bypassed you say arm I just go straight
to wit they just emailed studio with who
has no creative control over how attack
on Titans gonna end anyway I really want
I really wish that like studio we took
that email seriously and like actually
hooked up like you say I'm a being like
so uh this popular you know do you make
this a thing yeah please make this a
theme a season for attack on Titan I'm
ready I'm ready
hey you never know like none of us have
caught up on the manga yeah no no no
I feel like it's a crime to and if it
does happen we can thank a certain extra
castes a thing I know I know who break
out the beers
this has been a long time coming welcome
to trash taste podcast if you if you if
you want to know drinking is going to be
a quite frequent occurrence on this show
yeah so get used to it yeah so that was
I didn't imagine our intro was gonna be
that long ago in my head I was like a
[ __ ] finally I think it would you guys
will say that attack on Titan season 4
is your most anticipated Absa follow me
absolutely absolutely
how do you even match that hype at this
point it's like exeed it's uh it was
meant to be airing this fall I think oh
this summer I believe it was definitely
it was wrong but yeah I think it's I'm
pretty sure it's airing it was scheduled
to air next fall and I've heard from
because I made a video about the first
three seasons of attack on Titan and
I've heard from pretty much everyone
who's read the manga that season 4 is
going to be the best season oh no I mean
even if it was just mediocre I feel like
it we'd still like just think it's
amazing because like the journey to get
there it's been yeah and this last part
was oh my god oh my god like it's so
rare that you get to see a series just
improve over time every season because I
remember when attack on Titan season 1
was airing right and I was it was great
it was great but I felt like it was very
forgettable in a sense of well I
remember when season 2 aired I didn't
remember anything that happened in you
know what I remember specifically in
your video of their like season or
review you said remember their attack on
Titan and then you just play cricket
noises and
and our IRA be like well I'm watching
attack on Titan season 2 is good I think
like I know I do agree that the like
season 2 cuz season 1 when I watched it
I was like the high prisons yes and then
season 2 came around and actually
dropped it
no one cares because yeah because I
think I think what it was was that
because season 1 was you know all about
like the action and just like building
the world and yet season 2 was a lot of
politics and a lot of talking
yeah season 2 just took the pace cuz
season 1 was like a [ __ ] roller
coaster you were going up and down every
few episodes it's like you didn't know
what was gonna happen but you to me felt
a bit empty and season 2 you felt much
slower paced it was more of like a slow
burn when they focus more on the
characters yeah but I actually got
really drawn into the world way more
into season 2 but by the time Caesars
who ended I was like okay I'm now way
more invested but nothing really big has
happens yeah yeah I think everyone was
like what the [ __ ] we've waited four
years or something twelve well because
they rushed it out yeah I mean
definitely I think in season three when
that scene would leave I came out yes I
think when it just explode yeah yeah cuz
everyone saw that gif on Twitter I was
like I got a [ __ ] catch-up
okay see this is insane like just
thinking about that scene like gives me
goosebumps it's so good because I
remember season three part one I enjoyed
so [ __ ] much show cuz I didn't
realize I could care about the politics
that much in attack on Titan because I
remember by the time season 3 started I
was enjoying attack on Titan for
completely different reasons than season
one here on I mean III can say the same
thing about every season so I've heard
season four is going to be completely
different complete - what's previously
been because I mean like it was but me
and Aki went to the attack on Titan
exhibit mmm that they did in Roppongi
and basically it was really tough
because what what they did was
essentially they really catered to the
manga readers unfortunately yeah and I
am NOT the manga Rita so in like the
later rooms of the exhibit they
basically like on all the walls they
would have liked the original Ganga of
the manga right right in these frames
which is [ __ ] cool yeah but then as
you got further down the exhibit they
would start showing stuff that hadn't
been adapted yet right so I was like but
obviously there was just some stuff that
I couldn't really avoid see yeah and the
tiny little bits that I did see out of
context I was like what the [ __ ]
Wow there was no [ __ ] way that's
happening and then to top it off there
was this room this was like a really
experimental move on them their part but
there was this room that you had to go
into and it was a completely pitch black
room yeah and there's just audio playing
on the speakers in this pitch-black room
yeah and what that audio is is it's
audio of what sa AMA envisions the final
chapter or the tack on time to be
there's no visuals there's no visuals
it's just audio and it's what he
envisions it will sound like all of it
the only thing occurred was a lot of
like background noises like ambient
noises yeah and and mikasa yelling aaron
from a long way away okay that could
mean anything
I mean like I'm obviously not looking
the audio justice but it's can we get a
one-to-one reenact but I mean I'm
obviously not doing the audio justice
but it sounded like when I when I just
like closed my eyes and heard that I was
like wow I've never been more excited
for an anime in my life it's good to
know that the anime and the manga will
end with Mikasa screaming Eren a spoiler
has done for the entire [ __ ] series I
mean is that I mean it with the track
record the attack on Titan house right
now I mean it's I mean every episode you
could argue it's been really good right
I mean this story's just been there's no
like faults in the story so far right
it's holding up pretty well yeah I'd say
it's had been building on its story riot
really well really really well like what
if this if they nailed this ending what
like category is this in a flight
masterpiece master what what would you
put it is like
like anime in the same category man if
it killed that this last season like
this could even be in its own thing
we're like no anime is like as good I
would say that's that's not to say
that's a big statement right yeah but I
mean I'm just trying to think how many
like how many anime series have there
been where it's stretched out for I mean
over 50 episodes over 50 episodes like
let's say four or five seasons and has
like killed it this hog yeah I would say
it'd be similar to something like Full
Metal Alchemist
Hunter hunter although I'd say it's I
haven't seen full metal alchemist my
fanbase knows this it's a big [ __ ]
meme but Full Metal Alchemist is that
one anime that I haven't seen we all
have that one anyway I just when I think
about it I you know hunter hundreds I
mean hasn't ended there which is pretty
yeah I couldn't argue that's it's in the
same class but I guess full malakas
Brotherhood maybe you could yeah because
you never know like hunter and I might
I'm hoping yeah but you never know but
hunter hunter might end up like a Hugh
hockshop yeah I think that's the problem
is that I think everyone's got kind of
beginning to accept that slowly oh yeah
the world is just especially now with
the Dark Continent which you know it's a
load of stuff with Hunter hunter but
it's looking like it's even more
ambitious than before and he's not
releasing chapters no a very slow it's
it's is gonna take a whole lifetime to
catch up but going back to attack on
Titan I think I called it like if it's
even if it was off the quality of season
3 part 2 yeah and it all ended in that
quality it would be a modern classic oh
for sure my sure yeah if it's even
better than that I have no [ __ ] clue
but that makes me so excited yeah the
fact that we might be yeah he's just I
think the last time I was possibly that
excited for like a follow-up was one
punch man season 2
okay I've watched a few clips recently
up one punch man season 2 and he's like
wasn't that bad I think it's just a wish
set our expectations disgustingly hard
it wasn't bad it was painfully mediocre
it was like seven deadly sins season one
and then it like so what I'm hoping what
I'm hoping is that the net
season assuming we get another one at
one punch man is that it doesn't go my
god bat [ __ ] is still I like I haven't
seen any of seven deadly sins I don't
know anything about it never read the
manga never enemy but not gonna lie
there's a part of me when I saw footage
of season 3 yeah I was like I kind of
want to watch this now just to see it
devolve into this current state I
remember cuz the fight that they [ __ ]
up was one of the most likes it was one
of the most hyped fights and then they
[ __ ] it up so much that fan animation
of that fight that was released before
looked better than the official but when
I found out about that scene is someone
put it up on Twitter and had to preface
it by saying no this is not a fan
animation this is the official episode
because everybody in that tweet was like
is this fan made it's like some guy who
like just learn how to use flash like a
week ago just you know what sticks on my
mind that kick the kick when I give
first came and I saw the kick which
you'll probably see you on screen right
now I [ __ ] lost it like I don't think
I'd ever like I've watched all of seven
deadly sends up at that point and like I
wasn't like a huge fanboy but every time
a new season was announced of the OVA
I'd watched yeah I never so quickly lost
interest in a series just from seeing
that one screenshot melio dislike I was
like what did they do to him we've never
seen anything like has that happened in
anime before like where as season is
like so drastically like [ __ ] like
change Studios and lost I'm sure like I
know I know there have been and I know
I'm going to kill myself for not
remembering I like what this is but
there's been so many times that's
because the difference forces when it
happened back then is that there wasn't
Twitter and when it happens now oh you
know when it happens exactly it was just
like a bunch of light we'll talk
being like [ __ ] like the only thing I
can think of right now is like off the
top of my head is berserk or jaw which
it'll mean it's changed studio but it
was technically a continuation okay okay
okay what's worse that berserk the
second adaptation of berserk or the
seven deadly sins the new season yeah
okay because I mean like you know I'm
saying that from like a heart called
beserk fan I haven't heard the manga so
yes because if you'd read them if you
read the manga I'm sure everybody who's
read the manga can agree with this but
like I have never wanted to like cry
from sadness I'm like how could they do
my boy guts like that am i I've because
the berserk adaptation was just a
failure on pretty every level every
level from like the animation which
everyone likes points out boy like the
composition the sound design I mean if
you hear if you heard that like
[Music]
what sound it's just what how did you
get this who did you hire to be honest
[ __ ] came up with that sound like how
do you see this big [ __ ] iron sword
and just like let's pull out a cowbell
do you ever do a Jojo make everything a
gun show yeah every every honestly can I
talk about Jojo sound design I love Jojo
sound design so much cuz soun design is
something that people don't normally
talk about you know and you don't you
don't you don't really you don't release
his hair people who it's like voice
happening right well it's done well you
don't notice yeah so with Jojo sound
design it's one of the few shows where
if you hear if you hear like a sound you
know some judges you you know that you
know the exact stands and you know the
like sometimes it's the exact episode
and the exact fight because they're yeah
they're that recognized one that they're
like not generic at all and I [ __ ]
love Jojo sound design cuz the reason
why I think the anime is as good as is
one of the reasons is that the sound
design is so [ __ ] good
like have you guys seen the I assume you
guys have seen the Jojo Oh peas where
they add the sound so cool I don't know
why they don't do that for the the
airing versions I mean it's it's not
really what you see in an ope right it
is pretty unconventional but I mean
there's so many sounds that you could
say like I quite okay when you hear that
that gunshot for the punch you know it's
a Jojo pan yeah yeah and it makes it
sound so meaty it's great oh I love how
the punching sounds like every time you
know like this like a muda or like oh
yeah it is almost like gum like yeah I'm
sure it's like gunshot yeah yeah it's a
gunshot like and then obviously there's
a lardo timestop which I feel like it's
almost become the universal sound of you
know I mean if you talk musical oh my
god the new season absolutely killed it
it's like I think I think super ripe are
12 John said this and in his review of
golden wind and I feel the same way like
this is gone wind was the first
adaptation of a Jojo where I think the
anime is
because you know so much when you take
away that sound and especially the music
when you hear that journos theme come on
oh you're a sweetheart
Jonah's theme is one of the few tracks
in anime that has been memed to death it
is and I have no part I have more gotten
bored of it that's that's all outside
here but you like every version I've
heard of joiners theme of equally just
be tight it's like a piano version metal
version I don't care it's always been
sorry like when when we can go back to
the gym some of the best music to Pearl
when you're working out is JoJo's it
works so well and I know it should work
well but man when the piano hits you're
doing an extra rep no matter how tired
you are you're doing that extra rep it's
almost too hype sometimes there yeah
you're like oh [ __ ] I gotta keep doing
this rapper I'm dying right now
I don't know my boy Jojo down making of
anime adaptations though there is one
topic I would like to color because it
is quite timely yeah but just yesterday
actually reporting over as of us
recording this episode I found or I
guess Aki found that somebody is
adapting killing stalking you mean it's
not a big deal this is the biggest
opting killing stalking you mean when
andaman you mean it's not an official
anime adaptation like everyone on
Twitter thinks it is okay just like the
most is the original Twitter post that
blew this up said an official adaptation
and then in the replies to that tweet
they double down saying it yeah it was
all official but the thing that caught
my eye is the picture that everyone was
retweeting alright three pictures of
this tweet one of them there's like
chaos ops ops yeah so yeah so like cuz
kisaki found that on a timeline and was
like holy [ __ ] they're making us killing
slowking item adaptation I'm like really
let me see and I saw the pictures I'm
like the first two legit yeah oh yeah it
was like coming soon 2020 I was like oh
[ __ ] okay and then I looked at the last
one and it was like k ops ops to do
might yeah yeah right who what is the
student I legitimately had to look it up
on Wikipedia being like a baby's just
one of them cuz you know recently
they've been so many [ __ ] Japanese
anime studio yeah
come out with like ridiculous name so
I'm like I was probably just one of
those exactly I looked it up and I'm
like no it's literally just one dude one
dude but I feel bad for this derivative
making this cuz like my god the amount
of hikes they just got thrusted on them
and everyone's assuming this just like
legit yeah I mean how did the hype just
happen did they just literally just
between just the two it yeah but the
original tweet I think as of us
recording I think has like forty
thousand likes and like 20 thousand
retweets or something Wow
because killing stalking fans are
dedicated and also the thing was the
song Laura and the replies to that
people weren't questioning whether like
it was legit people what you're
questioning should it get an adaptation
no it's the main argument I think that's
why it was getting so many I think you
should get an adaptation I mean let me
let me chase the question have you guys
read it I've read the first like what is
it like cuz it came out like stories
right like seasons I said I watched I
read the first season and I quite liked
it and you know it's a lot but I feel
like from what I've heard as well it
handles it quite well towards the end
yeah I I did a video on it I actually
looked back on when I did my video of it
almost four years ago holy [ __ ] was it
that long ago yeah I remember you
releasing that like years ago and that's
because I only reviewed the first season
because I think the series ended like it
was like lost year yeah but there's like
a huge gap right so I've only really
seen or read like the first half of it
and it was you know it was marketed as
like oh it's a really hardcore like
gruesome Yowies yeah you know all these
fan girls getting on it and I was like
okay I mean I don't know if I'm gonna
enjoy it as much because I'm not exactly
the target demographic but I'll give it
a go and it was like a genuinely good
story like yeah it had Yowie elements in
it but you know I'm an adult I can
handle that yeah other than that if you
take away the young elements it's just a
really really good horror mystery but
when I saw that they were gonna make a
quote-unquote anime adaptation for it I
was like I don't I don't because
immediately what I thought of is all of
these other like over sexualized series
getting anime adaptation
recently because as someone who hasn't
read it seems like it's a very sexual
story that would have to be heavily said
it is is well I think it also has such
like its divided a lot of community cuz
I think a lot of people really sexualize
it yeah when it's just a really [ __ ]
up dynamic yeah and a lot of I mean a
lot of a really deep [ __ ] of like
possessiveness and and all that but if
you're thinking about reading it it's
it's a lot like going to it with caution
definitely be here for the huge of 80 we
have to legally say I mean I I think you
should read it but then also like I can
totally recommend you not to read it
like it's your life would be totally
fine if you don't read it yeah maybe I
love the anime instead talking about the
anime like I said affiliate I feel bad
for the this person because a lot of
people are putting a lot of hype on it
but also what I saw it's a one-man job
like these guys doing everything and I
don't know if it's a guy or girl but
they seem to be in charge of they seem
to be 3d modelers I think what that
trade is and I saw the voice-acting
casting call and as someone who's you
know done a lot of voice acting casting
calls I've made my own I've worked with
a lot of professional ones like it is
not normal
I'd say I don't even know I don't -
because they I don't think they're like
that experience and I think other voice
actors are helping them with it but
first of all normally you don't name
who's gotten what role publicly right so
on this casting call document which I
think we even maybe show on screen for a
second it says like one person who has
the role and it's showing publicly
that's not normally the case normally
it's just here are the lines audition
for it more yeah and the way it's laid
out is really odd and it's just over I
mean over Twitter isn't that weird but
there's no mention of pay or anything
like I guess I mean it is a fan-made
project but normally still you you say
if it's paid or not yeah you normally
say how you know how many lines they're
gonna be it just I don't know it looks
like it belongs on like casting call
Club which is an amateur voice acting
website yeah which makes me uneasy
because if it is gonna be a USB
microphone kind of deal it's not gonna
sound good because there was no there
was no hey here's the minimum require
into the sanitary room there was nothing
was just if you want to audition yeah
and I saw the replies to this thread and
it was like all thirteen Ewald sounding
girls auditioning yeah but that's
because the main [ __ ] like readership
oh yeah smoking our thirteen-year-old
girls yeah though it shouldn't be from
purely based on context it should not be
it's just worrying with these kind of
things as well because normally like
when I've done plus eighteen project I
normally ask for proof of ID yeah and if
I cast someone like they need to show me
their ID and this should definitely be
one of the situations where I like those
those precautions should be taken yeah
even if it's fan-made right like yeah
not a good look for you if you you're
getting thirteen old girls to voice in
your thing about like it's still very
early days I mean it's from what it
sounds like it sounds like a situation
where someone just way too much press
got way too much press way too quickly
because I have no doubt that they
probably have no [ __ ] experience
because I saw on their Twitter actually
just this morning yeah they tweeted out
being like oh my god after someone
retweeted my thing I've gained like ten
thousand Twitter followers in like
overnight and like you know this person
obviously like came from Lee pretty much
close to zero phone yes so for them
that's a lot yeah that's that's a lot of
like pressure just immediately built up
on them yeah because you're going after
such like I don't wanna say iconic but
like a very like very very dedicated
series no I think it's not just that as
well because I think what really built
up the hype as well as we're in like
this environment now where webtoons
anime it cumbia are being major so it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be it wouldn't
have been so surprising to say killing
Stalkings getting an anime as opposed to
like last year even two years ago where
you know we didn't have any presidents
for that now with tower of god airing
and god of high school and knobblies
all guessing animes it's like maybe
we're in a new era where people are
expecting that's their favorite webtoons
or their favorite web comics or whatever
country is could get anime adaptations
yeah
I mean to be fired I wouldn't be against
the idea of it actually getting an
official adaptation the only stolen yeah
I think it could be definitely make
waves I mean it would make sense
considering that recently there's been
like a big trend of like as I said
earlier like over sexualized seriously
we've got a shoe mats in a harem yeah my
[ __ ] god how they gonna handle how
are they gonna handle that because there
is legitimately a sex scene everything
like I'm not even kidding so III don't
know anything about this monographs
earlier what is it called again it's
called shoe mutts on a hair or worlds
and Harold in a harem and basically the
the overall plot I'm over simplifying
this but basically it's a hemorrhoid
plot
humanity has gone to [ __ ] where there is
a disease that is killing all males it's
affecting males so basically now you can
tell males now are becoming like a
commodity they're basically being
treated like males that have like to
survive this disease yeah basically like
treated as like national let me guess
right first of all the difference
between this and hentai right is that if
it was a hentai it being ugly bastard
but like the dynamic see this is where
difference from a hint either is that
our main character has like this girl
that he's been thinking about his whole
life yeah and basically like doesn't
want to just go around and like yeah
yeah sex everyone in order to save he
met he'd rather keep his like purity for
the goal that he leaves been thingy
crazy it's about it's about waiting for
the right person it's basically blue
ball feed the monitor because everyone
else all five other guys having a
[ __ ] great time they're [ __ ] you
different chicks every [ __ ] yeah
they're pretty much they're pretty much
like what
hinto protagonist should be I'm not
being sold on this but saying that I
wasn't solving than two species
reviewers until I watched it I thought
this is pretty funny it's not gonna be
as good in two species reviews is like a
really weird case because it was
something that was definitely deaf
the Itchy in the manga in the manga in
the anime they just made it poor but I I
still like I I still I know in species
reviewers to me is that line between
hentai and itchy because you don't watch
interspecies reviewers to jack off right
oh yeah but it's undeniable that there
is just a straight-up sexiness which is
really interesting though because the
one sex scene that everyone was raving
on about in the anime I think was
episode 4 3 3 episode 3 was never in the
manga no it wasn't it was implied all
sex scenes of that series isn't your
slide in the manga but in the anime that
was just like [ __ ] it let's just show it
yeah like put things in perspective you
didn't even see nipple in the manga wow
that was that was like no you seen this
man's Twitter he knows a nipple when
he's in all the volumes and I've enjoyed
every single one can we talk can we talk
about your Twitter and a bit clip is why
can you please explain your Twitter and
okay whenever I go on Twitter right I
don't follow
hentai artists on Twitter because I
don't need to because this man's got me
cuz as you know on Twitter when you when
you like when you like a picture there's
a good chance for some reason especially
Joey's typically it comes on my Twitter
and I'm a scan at least every time I
open for a 6 or 7 like either like
full-on sex things or like very very
lewd it's always Joey it's like I'm like
I don't follow porn Oh like by Joey
Bissinger and it's like how did you get
to this point he's what I don't
understand right like how many people do
you follow on Twitter like on average
600 something about about that many okay
right you both follow about over 500
people yeah and like this isn't just you
to like I've had this from like mutual
friends of mine everyone says it's you
how is it that my likes end up on
everybody's fine
am I like am i only twitter preferred
like what I have no [ __ ] clue per it
it is I'd say 70 to 80% of the time I
see Lutz on my timeline it is you it is
true [ __ ]
first of all you're welcome okay because
this used to be the case and yeah I
swear you were way more timid about it
how did how did it cuz I'm scared of
doing that cuz i I don't know cuz I I
mean I shouldn't really excite you get
half naked so my videos but yeah I don't
know I was I was worried about like
she's just having porn on my thing but
not I guess I could get away with
because how did you go from not sharing
porn to basically just to being beat the
hentai I've always shared that's the
thing have you didn't I mean maybe not
as frequently no no I know you're
seeking I I think it's it was just
Twitter changing the like button to be
basically the because for the entirety
that I've been on Twitter yeah I've
liked hentai yeah because I followed
hint I like people like hentai other
side like yeah I've discovered but I've
never retweeted it because of this exact
reason I don't want other people's
timelines but Twitter was just like hey
let's just like make the like button
like a raider retweet button
I got us how much of your feet is just
head that's why I asked to see his phone
do you want to see you nail it wasn't
that bad when I first saw it I mean the
thing is I don't follow that mini Han
Toyotas yeah I know that's hard to
believe
but I I genuinely don't the thing is I
follow a hand Thai artists that love
retweeting other hand time yeah yeah and
that's where I find all the people okay
scroll scroll through what you scroll
down which we don't see let's see how
many how many come up that one one in
three can you also like everyone that it
was likes from one this is oh yeah go to
Ike's go to my likes oh that's another
one that's two in a row oh wait there's
a Jimmy Neutron that that's not meant I
was
oh yeah that's basic okay let me while
they're looking through this widow let
me defend myself real quick okay the
reason why I like it is because at the
end of the day these are just drawings
right there's a difference between
liking like actual human pawn versus
just a picture this man's about to go
the hens eyes are true I am genuinely
one of those people who looks at hantai
as odd no I totally agree with you I'm
talking on behalf of every hand tire
lover watching this episode including
you I'm Kent I just I don't know if I
look at it and like just cracker but a
beer and just enjoy boy no no I've
gotten to that point right I've gone to
the point you will see in my you see my
[ __ ] room you see my [ __ ] office
which is just like full of like anime
thighs and stuff like that because it's
gone to the point where sometimes you
just see this like drawing of a girl or
thigh or something and I just don't even
get horny anymore I'm just like I'm just
I'm just [ __ ] impressed about how
they make it look how good they make it
yeah that was me when I saw them le
odessan 70 because they're genuinely
like some hentai artists that I've seen
and I know of where I'm just like if you
made an all-ages manga yeah you would
sell like crazy oh no people have people
and people have like look at like Nana
she who made um [ __ ] easier and they
than that of a song yeah I love everyone
everyone has seen this chick before
alright now that she was originally like
a hardcore loli hantai artist yeah
and he made a really [ __ ] successful
all a just call me manga which is
hilarious yeah and like and then and
even if they don't make all a just stuff
look at artists like nepata who is like
genuinely an amazing artist yeah and
that's what I will like because you know
we've gotten to this point where hentai
has just become like haha anime boobs
hilarious and horny on me like it's all
just become like a joke thing yeah I
don't want that
I don't I don't want but I'm sick of
those jokes I'd like I want to save this
table because I was so III already get a
whole episode I'm ready I have too many
things to say about hentai and anti
artists that I can't fit it all slide
like five minutes much like on this
episode if you want to hand my episode
cuz we're gonna do it either way we're
gonna do it and give these guys like
three sips of beer and they just start
talking about anti like I don't know
like what I watch hentai it's like it's
for a service you know I guess I do it
too I do the deed right like I don't sit
there and like swirl my wine glasses
am i weird am i okay I want yes it's
probably the answer it's the way am i
weird to be like sometimes I kind of
just want to watch hand-tied just do it
yes that's he's going through that phase
right now that's why I'm sure III don't
I hem tied to me hasn't got to that
point right dojinshi and manga there's
there is no part of me in a porn where
like I watch a porn lighter immediately
skips two minutes in you know you you
are you are the degenerate err
[ __ ] I've bought a lot of
dojinshi from like artists I like yeah I
don't think I've actually read like
physical copies of dashi and like jacked
off to it I know that's TMI I'm sorry
yeah I will recommend you some [ __ ] okay
I do I'll come on a little light in like
in like four episodes I'll come back
I'll totally agree with everything these
guys say I know I just referred to like
your like progression from like oh what
the [ __ ] - like you know what I love
this artist yeah because it's if you've
read enough - gingy and if you've read
enough your page manga there are so many
dodging cheese that just have really
really good plots
yeah and and it's it's this sips beer I
hire to agree I must say it's gotten to
this point where sometimes you just want
the series to be adapted into a hentai
just so you can see it animated yeah and
sometimes you've read the series that
just
do something new with porn or hem side
they just and have never seen before
yeah like wow this is like awakening
something in me right now this is
amazing okay no I've never heard someone
describe I've watched em tight and it
awakened something that I've read where
like at first I was like okay I dig this
art and then I see like the edge he
scenes and I'm like okay I'm digging
this like you know may I have like a
quarter charming but then as the story
continues I'm like you know what the
guys [ __ ] the HTC casts are the wrong
boys that question to you and question
to all of you watching why do you think
thighs hot thigh highs are sexy and if
the answer isn't anime an anime awakens
your love for thigh highs your [ __ ]
life oh I did it did I mean because
let's be real Japanese girls don't have
five yeah yeah so like if you just think
if you fire highs is like entry level
right in the world of the jinn she's in
hate monger okay that's like southern or
me [ __ ] man happy with by - or me as
[ __ ] maybe in future we can return to
this topic when I've you know done my
research
yeah so we're getting ahead of ourselves
right now okay like this this was meant
to be an introductory episode when we
introduce what we won't even don't like
these topics I'm sorry it won't always
be hentai by the way because preface
that I just but I think that I mean the
main reason we started this as well
because we always hang out together like
it's it's not one of those things like
some youtubers hang out they make videos
seems like their friendships great we
all actually hang out together all the
[ __ ] time and we always talk for like
two hours yeah what looking at and
essentially what we do on a daily yeah
like we easily have conversations where
we just talk for like three hours about
manga anime and we're like why don't we
just [ __ ] not even about manga or
anime anyway and I remember the last
time we were at your house and we talked
about like what was the best burger
joint really legitimately late
about like is in and out overrated or
not for like it's not it's not by the
way it is okay we're gonna get into but
I suppose uh I guess that's we're gonna
be talking about like anything and it's
evolved over the time yeah I mean the
core of is anime and manga I mean I have
a lot of things about anime manga that I
want to talk about but I also want to
talk about the culture the community
hentai more henselae yes yeah and I mean
I'm also like just general because we
all were youtubers we'd want to talk
about sometimes if there's YouTube drama
that we feel like we can probably add
something of course well you know
sometimes if there's just like standard
banter of just laying on whatever the
[ __ ] then yeah well if any of our
Mutual's are ever in japan like if you
want to talk anime and manga with us hit
us up yeah
and not even just our Mutual's like if
you're just if you want to like come on
to the show and my talk first of all you
gonna come on to the show physically sit
sit right here names because we wanna
ideally this will be a four-person
podcast and hopefully we I mean I'd be
really interested in to bring youtubers
on who don't really get to talk about
anime yeah I guess yeah I mean if there
are any youtubers watching this video or
you know the tweet or whatever
Suzanne I guess let us know if you'd
like to come onto the podcast because we
will happily welcome because it's it's
surprising I've met so many youtubers
who have nothing to do with anime or
anything to watch anime who watch anime
and just really want to talk about anime
too so yeah I think I think it's pretty
awesome because I remember anime was
nowhere near this popular before oh yeah
and I remember the feeling of being the
only anime fan and haven't having there
nothing I don't want to talk about I
mean I think that's why I started my
youtube channel yeah like that was like
my reasoning is that I hadn't no want to
talk to this about let's just say like
kids today have it like you're an anime
fan like this a day in high school you
have it so much easier than any of us
did my god I wish I I'm so jealous
because I wish I could have just talked
to my [ __ ] friends about Naruto
or one piece or Santa convinced my
friends to get into anime God in order
for them in order to find someone to
talk about
this is like another thing that I when I
talk to Americans they don't have this
problem at least in my age group I
imagine yours as well right yeah it's
like we at Americans had it good but
British people and I think probably
standing people are more closer to
British like [ __ ] ruthless at school
oh yeah
like and I remember I got [ __ ] for
gaming too much at school so how the
[ __ ] am I gonna [ __ ] for gaming too much
in school so how am I gonna sit there
and be like alright so Call of Duty that
thing that you play but give me [ __ ] for
how about you check out these anime
titties right I I built up years getting
to like a medium level of like yeah in
between a level of popularity yeah but I
got out of the bullying zone if you will
didn't want to go back to you look crazy
just how like I don't wanna say
mainstream mainstream yeah it's not
mainstream at all but like I guess just
how much more accepted it's become as a
sub it's good it's good yeah it's
definitely definitely is because I feel
like anime works so well meme culture oh
my god you know what I mean yeah an
anime in a sense is meme culture in a
lot of ways I mean I'm flying a room
when you mentioned meme culture and
anime you all know what we're talking
about yeah but I feel like because of
that it's a lot more people know what
anime is or at least have seen a meme or
a screenshot or a gift
yeah of probably Joe Joe will happen as
it should be it's the only animal that
matters and then people would just
recognize that a lot more because I
remember when I was growing up people
didn't even know what anime was yeah the
words animated they're like what the
[ __ ] is this year yeah that's some
cartoon porn [ __ ] you know what I mean
yeah absolutely it's weird because I
think one of the biggest like
double-edged swords to anime has been
Netflix like in the sense that like it's
got a lot of people into anime yeah but
then when you get really into anime it
becomes like the [ __ ] worst place to
go oh definitely gonna talk about light
and tore that more future but I also
helped locks I mean they've been pushing
like I remember like when they start
getting anime like death
would not get off my [ __ ] recommend
it on at Netflix really yeah yeah and
like full metal lockers Brotherhood I
think they have that I think they have
like all the classics which is pretty
impressive yeah yeah I mean they have
all the entry level right the stuff that
means they need to watch and now they
have even galleon this one yeah yeah
exactly which is crazy but your
achievement I can't imagine how much
money Netflix through be like hey can we
grab your series that has been pretty
much out of print for like 20 plus years
I want to hear the story about how they
got that because people have tried for
decades literal decades to get to get
the after adv died to get the licensing
over to the west so that must be a
winner lots and lots of money I actually
couldn't believe it
yeah like this is like one of the
biggest achievements because it is like
like you know without you know wrapping
it up in a package nicely like
Evangelion is one of the best anime like
ya ever made and like I know we all know
Arno is like hardcore when it comes to
protecting his IP Oh cuz remember for
the longest time
Hollywood wanted to make that a ver Adam
yeah yeah and I know was just like how
the [ __ ] off there are so many [ __ ]
live-action adaptations being made right
now I can't even keep track of them all
remember when there was just one and
everyone would just wait to [ __ ] on that
one oh no I think there's like over ten
adaptations being made right now we need
to do an episode or we do like a tier
list of the worst Netflix adaptations
all right we need to do a tier list of
the world buyback sure anyways guys look
forward to all of that stuff this was
just a taster we didn't really plan much
of what we were gonna say as you can see
we're just talking out of our army we
were just there was a topic planned and
we just kind of evolved yeah we only we
talked about was kingly stalking which
last five minutes there'll be a lot more
structure in future when we get a bit
more used to it as well we have more
topics to talk about but because right
now we do want to cover I think it would
make it really interesting for you the
audience from you know you hear our
opinions pretty early on about things
that are like evolving situations yeah
also if you want to hear
anything or if you want to request
anything that you want to hear us talk
about you can tweet at us yes at trash
taste pod go onto Twitter and give us
your suggestions if you guys would also
like to ask like any questions like Q&A
and stuff like that yeah we'll probably
have a Q&A so yeah and then we'll
probably grab some questions off of
Twitter as well basically if you'd like
to interact with us in any way for
future episodes then definitely follow
us on Twitter
yeah and also [ __ ] like button fan
but if you do then that would greatly
help us out and as you can see we're
still in like I'd say like beta right
now the beta stage of this podcast yeah
we're gonna need a mistake yeah we're
gonna we're gonna be filling up the
background and everything I'm sorry
about that if you found this episode and
enjoyed it before we even pushed it on
our main channels thank you it's like
yeah I really appreciate it guys yeah I
think that's a good place to end it for
now yeah we're gonna be uploading at
least one a week and we have a
highlights channel as well coming out so
yeah you can expect at least one of
these a week look forward to that guys
thanks for watching I've been Joey I've
been gone Connor or c-dawg Virginia
peacock geek UK and we appreciate you
guys for sticking around this first
episode and we hope to see you guys in
the next one alright
nice bye bye